this is like Christmas in January for us
if you see anything you like you can
have it who told you you could take all
the stuff welcome back to corridor
cruise its 2019 we got big plans here in
the studio my biggest plan that I've
been thinking about over all Christmas
break is building a perfect camera
system to do that and you get all our
equipment in order so we need to go
through the camera room which hasn't
been organized in like two years
clear it out get rid of all the stuff we
don't need it all stuff we do need and
get it accessible get it place in the
right spot and make it so anybody can
walk in and whatever they're looking for
yeah we're gonna icing by category oh we
got bags we have rigging stuff camera
stuff we have lighting stuff we have
batteries what stuff I need putting a
pile this if you don't need throw it
away don't fly through look at these
hands man some dirty analyst Wow you
leave I had to change the font because
you left to give us some drones man now
look at it now now it's all off I'm
gonna redo that man bye deal no man
that's my deal here do your font on this
I had a great Christmas we did the the
grand tour of Minnesota and central
Wisconsin first time bringing the kid
out to the snow he loves it he's a
natural stayed in the house that had
internet but no TV that means I couldn't
play Red Dead 2 so now I'm playing it
now dude house cleaning bills man so
house cleaning goes so good yeah I was
in there by myself those peaceful thing
ever yesterday there was like four
people in there it will have a got
stressed out dude
I don't know if I get stressed easily
but like there's like four cooks in the
kitchen I'm saying
it's kind of organized so what's all
this this is like we need to get rid of
this this is the stuff we don't eat
anymore so we get to keep it we get to
say does any of it work
yeah really let me get this what is this
play is the stuff that we intend to get
rid of this is like Christmas in January
for us if you see anything you like
you can have it that's what this pottery
the control for this thing Nick you need
pretty beefy steel tripod where you
found something maybe a router it's like
what Jake fell off oh all these extra
ports that you can plug all the cool
stuff in like a foot Hugh oh this takes
that one battery home RAID storage got a
couple dimmers here that's pretty sweet
actually I'm gonna think this is my
exercise it's a new year 2019 and with
that comes some great sponsors like
today's episode sponsor Skillshare and I
gotta say it's very serendipitous timing
because I don't know if you guys know
this but back at the homestead I got a
new kid he's about to turn five months
old my wife was like hey Jake we need to
take baby photos before the kid gets too
old and well she's asking again and I
need lights so everybody's been cleaning
the studio and all that and I heard from
Clint that Sam heard from Niko that
Niko's givin away stuff on this table
sweep this is a 120 D yeah this is
perfect because in the Skillshare video
that I was watching which if you guys
don't know Skillshare is an online
learning community with over 25,000
classes that teach you about a bunch of
things including filmmaking and I saw
one in there where this guy's teaching
you how to use lighting to create layers
with a 120 D I'm going to take these
home I'm gonna create some light layers
that I learned on Skillshare I'm going
to isolate my foreground subjects with
ground highlights and I'm gonna make
some beautiful baby photos after already
making some beautiful babies now a
premium membership to Skillshare gives
you unlimited access to all the classes
whether you're looking to just do
something creative or you're looking to
improve your career Skillshare is a
great place to learn in 2019 let's set
this up if you guys are interested in
signing up for Skillshare it's less than
ten bucks a month and the first 500
people to sign up using the link in the
description below will get two months
free but only for those 500 people you
know my feeling is about Skillshare we
could all be a little bit brighter if we
brought it into our lives
click yeah you know how many days have
you been in here this is day 3 in the
equipment den looks really nice it's not
done though like look at this pile I've
got to get that out of here one more day
I think I think I can get it done today
it's your last day my last day because
next week I got videos to do how's the
cleaning going boys good so good dude
clean it up it's important to take
breaks that's true reckon
[Music]
Nick where's all that stuff
I think everyone took what they wanted I
just have some lights I might sell these
I might give them to somebody who needs
them more than we do I heard they're
free who told you you could take all the
stuff okay okay
these I'm trying to get them out of the
studio you already know how to fly
drones we have four more drones if you
want to fly a drone wait who told you to
take all the gear off to Clinton did you
tell everybody they could take gear off
the table that was all free well yeah
cause I thought you were putting all
that stuff is stuff we're gonna be
donating or throwing away so it was like
might as well as well just having people
who grabs it yeah we got through it yet
but like if you're gonna give away it's
like things I want in that file and I
want what if I want them dear to this we
have five-door Gimbels in there why can
I just take that one you guys have five
cameras in there five Gibble's in there
to use yeah just want to practice you
know then take one of the Gimbels film
that we will use that way you're
practicing with the gimbal that we will
use we're trying to get rid of this
stuff
so I can't have this only it's for
training possible I didn't say you could
have this camera I feel bad for you you
can have this
dude that's a pity routers are gonna
stop Friday please stressing me out
the moment when you are done with that
room I will go through this table and I
will separate things into what people
can take and what people can't take I
got collect all this in here take it
back wait what who told you that it was
on the get rid of table because it
didn't have to go through it and figure
out create here is my bring out your
dead gear Bell this is not in the
giveaway pile but this is on the is on
the table because they're just trying to
take it out of the camera room wait Jake
if you need a light we have lots of
great lights Garrett I can do what
Corinne said take it all look everyone I
promise that once I go through the table
all you guys to send out like madmen
especially you rent
final stretch just making sure
everything is all good and organized for
the official walkthrough the Board of
Directors Board of Directors meeting yes
I'm solo CD buy everything then at a
good like 50% right now like my OCD
meters always add an ad I just realized
that man because no matter how clean to
get there's always something so we the
spec dumbest somewhere just sneaking on
by dude that's just this just alluding
dude your lens it's complete Bruce Lee
Niko Sam J I'd love to show you the
fruit of my Labor's I'm not easily
impressed this is the done room what
happened stop okay as a walk through the
park stuff's missing true
most of it was trashed let me walk you
guys through we go this is the battery
station where you will find your
battery's charged or not charged you'll
find this bin it says charge me that
means any battery that needs a charge
goes inside of this bin they have we
have a GoPro charging Bay the B locks
the gold mounts to get all of our
walkies
stinger fingers to all the tape and then
this whole middle section right here our
lights this is the whole sound area of
your sound kit really to my ears whole
camera station cinema arms your red
parts your rigging your filters and
rings this is the networking storage
station harddrive accessories your
readers and your network cards all
drives that we have used and put into
storage and this table is absolutely
under no circumstances is anything to be
on the table period you're gonna put
something there and it's gonna fall over
and hit the keyboard and it's gonna hit
delete on something and leave something
on this table get a quick stir number up
like like your middle finger like this
we got a little bit of space doesn't
mean we have to fill the space
so I'm philosophy that good organization
means that somebody who's never been in
this room before knows where to get
something and also knows where something
goes without having to ask anybody so
Gabe hasn't been in this room since
clean cleaned it by believing every I
would like to you to put these two
things away where do you think they go
[Applause]
gave incredible success can you please
get me a harddrive reader done such a
great job organizing this room I'm so
proud of you great with everything
organized knowing where all our gear is
knowing exactly what we have I am ready
to build the perfect camera oh oh this
is super cool actually I put this you
know I've taken this you know a lot
about one wheels can you help me